you of course voted against the Prime
Minister's deal he's been very vocal in
the reasons that you don't think it's a
good idea what would she have to do to
win your support first of all the Prime
Minister needs to hold a nerve I think
we've seen a lot of movement over the
last week coming from the EU you know
we've heard them say we've had to talk
about rather than having a backstop and
a border between Britain and Northern
Ireland we haven't talked now possibly
between the EU and Island so we're
hearing stuff like this we've also heard
this week about the French farmers
fearing as having moving on a No Deal
and also the fishermen you know we're
having ministers in France saying that
their fishing industry could be
destroyed because traffic for them so
they are starting to get a reality check
now the EU they've been doing all this
brinksmanship so I think first of all
the Prime Minister needs to hold a nerve
secondly I'd like to see have been the
backstop but completely completely it
would have fight with a time limit
enough to win you and I think there
needs to been it completely I mean we've
seen the report that Steve Baker and as
released this week along with Peter
Lille showing an alternative and let's
not forget the ERG came up with you know
a policy in which we can use existing
technology without Owen Paterson out at
the borders at the same time though at
the same time though and we spoke to
Islands Europe Minister only show Helen
McEntee she said that there's no
compromise no backstop well so someone
yes thank you right but with respect you
know they are they get so much subsidies
Islanders from the EU they would say
that they would be you know retorting
exactly what they because they're
worried about the border they're worried
about peace but let's not forget as well
with the ERG papers that we've had over
the last few months
Lord Trimble who was involved in the
peace process has been involved with
ease and has recommended these
alternative solutions now and also if we
look at the EU they gave they've
suggested back in March last year about
the Canada plus I mean if we can extend
that for Northern Ireland then that's
fantastic then we are delivering on our
manifest
how about thinking that you know the EU
and Island have been so and steadfast in
saying that the backstop cannot be
negotiated and if you're not willing to
accept it then it presumably means that
you'd be happy to go to WTO you'd be
happy to go to No Deal so just say that
oh well I'm not afraid to say that
you'll see I'm on Twitter
accession I'm not afraid to say that
Sophie so it's really about negotiating
the deal no it is because I mean
ultimately I want to see a deal but not
a deal that the EU's wrote it's got to
be a deal on our terms I mean let's not
forget that when we leave that you you
will be their largest trading partner
you know bigger than the US bigger than
China
you know we hold that 39 billion pounds
that works out over sixty million pound
pair constituency that could be spent
here in Britain and we've got a trade
deficit on goods with EU there's some
far more tourism we do to them you know
they want a deal just as much as we do
however it's got to be mutually
beneficial we don't want the EU writing
it and you can say that they have
compromised as well oh yes but but let's
not forget back in 2016
Varney a said I think it was in Lapointe
newspaper that his job is to give such a
bad deal to the UK post breaks it that
they would want to remain well I think
that the Prime Minister and I want to
chief negotiators need to stand up and
not take that we need to put our country
first and they want a deal if we leave
on WTO and have that competitive
advantage they will not like that okay
now it's no secret of course that the
Conservative Party is pretty split over
brexit right now and I just want to have
both parties know that's I I think
that's why politicians and the country
perhaps and but I just want to have a
look at something he said four months
before the referendum in 2016 you were
asked about how the party would come
together afterwards and you said it took
18 years for the Conservatives to have a
majority government we're not going to
mess it up
are you messing it up now because
sometimes it kind of look like that's
what's happening and I think it is a
mess completely I mean a viet my hat a
few times you know I said the Prime
Minister was on borrowed time and I've
eat my hat several times I should still
there you know but let's face it
politics is you know it's very hard to
predict at the moment so he who's the
right leader to guide the concept of
parties out of this mess well I
I'm a Democrat this is why I don't want
a second referendum and I our my
colleagues and I we've had a vote yes I
wanted a new leader but I think it's too
late now we are weeks away you know so I
respect the decision in our party that
they in the future perhaps I think it
depends what how we end up chose your
exit it depends if with some in a mess
then it should be a brexit here if it's
if we're in a good place which I'd
rather hope that is the case then it
could open up to other people in my
honesty
now one thing I'd like to say what I've
read in the news today that maybe we
also ought to replace Ollie robins with
with mr. mayor's achieve negotiator
couldn't seems like he's talking more
sense at the moment that is an idea
thank you very much for being on program
this morning